hello, how are you, sali
jaramillo with the briefing for today monday
may 10 until this morning it is known that
the north las vegas police are
looking for two suspects involved in
a fatal shooting that occurred in the shopping
center near zenten me and  swings
around nine thirty at
night the authorities said that these
two approached the
victim's vehicle and one of them shot him and
killed him
if you have information about this
incident contact alto el crimen at
70 23 85 55 55
tomorrow  you can drive through the saxo
station and receive the
corona virus vaccine from the comfort of
your car appointments will be available
from 7 am to
noon 7 days a week this
clinic will be open for six weeks
to facilitate the cycle  vaccination
for more information visit our
disney diagonal page in Spanish
on the other hand the allianz library
will reopen in new beams the location  a
in election will reopen on
June 1st both sites will operate at 50
% capacity computer use
will be limited to one hour some
programs will still run online
and now we turn to the weather forecast
for today we will have clear
sunny skies  With temperatures reaching the
high 80s for tomorrow we will see
similar temperatures
however get ready because we will
exceed the 90s for the rest of the
week today is
Mother's Day in Mexico very happy day I am Sali
Jaramillo and this was the brief
newsletter of the Spanish edition
[Music]